alors les amis dans quelle région de
france avec vous voyagez aujourd'hui
alors je ne sais pas du tout de quelle
région parle comme on dit qu'on vote
dans le style quand tu parles de l'ess
et la bretelle se serait pas un indice
sur l'atelier qu'elle a pris d'assaut
brasse les feuilles oui elle fait
référence à sa fameuse robe avec des
feuilles du feuillage ou alors tout
simplement elle aime ça les feuilles
peut-être qu'elle a la main verte
peut-être qu'elle et jardiner that an
ernst young est ce que tu fais là
meilleure imitation de de l'éternuement
de johnny hallyday c'est vrai ou pas
j'en fais une je passais la meilleure
mais c'est vrai cette histoire tu l'as
déjà rencontré oui j'ai lu j'ai eu la
chance en face de lui et donc les images
et des gens qui connaissaient à un
moment donné pendant qu'il parlait il a
éternué et la terre s'arrêta
à l'envers
pour cette vidéo arnaud gérad champion
du monde d'apnée a plongé sous 1 courant
puissant celui des rouleaux de taille
pour au large de tahiti spots de surf
iconique qui accueillera les épreuves de
paris 2024 où les vagues peuvent
attendre dix mètres de haut mais ce site
est aussi dangereux car sous l'eau le
fonds fait appelant m la chorégraphie
est précise et le spectacle à couper le
son
[Musique]
c'est sûr que
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça ne m'intéresse pas trop réfléchir en
vrai je pense que on se porte mieux si
on réfléchit pas trop parce que ça nous
permet de ne pas ne pas casser le moment
en famille il y a une seule règle la
justice d'accord c'est à dire et la
danseuse non mais ce qui est
extraordinaire je n'oublie pas ce qu'il
ya qu une seule règle la pause à toute
une
série d'infractions
tromperait s'il vous dit que ça fait une
semaine que je m'entraîne à mettre un
short un tueur pour dormir
[Musique]
non j'ai l'habitude de dormir sans sous
vêtements et ses très jeunes ou qui
louent au mais
là ça m'a fait flipper
tu vois ça c'est des vrais questions ça
il a du temps répond de la même question
c'est pas très rassurant
j'ai une mémoire de poisson rouge et
battraient bien taillé des morts deux
parce qu'on mange boit son malin très
bien maintenant tu vas t'en souvenir du
poète ne suis pas souvent encore du beau
linge sur la moquette il a fallu père à
chauray le fonds vert de la météo ce qui
est très pratique pour disparaître sur
le tapis attention at disparition
[Musique]
semble être oui c'est un souffleur mont
louis qu'est ce que tu penses de cette
question sur une nouvelle étude salaires
en feignant ou autre chose par rapport
au testing sur l'effet brésil du 4 bis
dirait l'autre tu dirait l'autre
d'accord derrière l'autre il y as
salé ratatine
ce ne sont pas les même temps que j'y
suis
tu peux pas dire ça chez
moi
j'ai dit si on continue je vais pas
pouvoir sortir de la piste
[Musique]
elle aimait dont septième ciel l'extase
oui
à l'extase 6 à 5 louis
saha les rentes hadid
et louis par rapport à la réponse des
vals est
celle
ci le corps commence on va recommencer
gilles verdez c'est pas un problème
qu'est ce qu'il a bâti lui dis ce que tu
as lui dire j'ai rien à lui dire c'est
une oeuvre d'art
abbas est l'oeuvre d'art si vous le
mettez en bas de la tour eiffel tous les
pieds tous les chiens ont pissé dessus
mauvaise surprise sur instagram pour
madonna qui a découvert ce message en
lançant un live la semaine dernière
phase
difficile à croire pour la star mais
c'est bien là la sanction de la
plateforme suite à des publications
contraires aux règles d'utilisation
une réaction peut-être au nfc 3d posté
la semaine dernière où une version
numérique de madonna apparaît nue
pourtant ce jour là pour une fois elle
s'était bien tenu à venir
et je tue des gens
avec qui on dit
c'est bon tu vas arrêter de parler à
tous les mecs qui ont été condamnés tu
vas pas parlé à grand monde tu vas
rester seul déjà que tu vis du seul
comme un rat comme tu es là tu vas vivre
tout seul mon pote mais là je vais te
dire ce que tu viens de faire là je peux
te dire un truc que je vais m'occuper de
mon cas
bonsoir